[Music]
matt is in san bernardino california hi
matt how are you
hi guys how you guys doing today better
than we deserve sir how can we help
perfect i just want to make this quick i
have a quick question for you so it's
about making a mistake on skipping the
baby step
so i
had about twenty thousand dollars in
savings by the age of 23 i'm now 24. i
started a business i lost it all
but then i got in touch with dave ramsey
and i realized i didn't i had debt that
i should have paid off before i started
a business so i have eight thousand
dollars left
to pay off on my car loan out of twenty
two thousand i have approximately four
thousand dollars in my stocks that could
help me get out of debt in three months
instead of six months so i thought i
could skip baby step two because the
interest was so low
but i just feel like a slave now
okay
well uh the the paradox is is that if
you
the very nature of skipping a baby step
means you didn't take the baby step
right yeah
well played dave
dave was in honors classes matt
i had to learn that the hard way
we've all been there man so what we're
really saying is
are you really now ready to follow this
system or are you going to continue to
do math system
no i'm i'm completely ready to uh okay
then our system is you would liquidate
anything that is not retirement
anything you can sell
that you don't have to have that's not a
retirement account
and down to one thousand dollars in
savings that's baby step one and
everything else goes on your debt which
is your car right
right so your stocks are worth four
thousand what else do you have you can
liquidate
um i just sell my motorcycle okay what's
it worth
uh probably about two thousand okay says
something on my screen about crypto tell
me about that
yeah so uh all of my all the four
thousand is in my crypto and individual
stocks okay so that's the total
portfolio okay all right so you
liquidate that um and you make what a
year
50 000. what'd you say the motorcycle
was worth
about 2 000.
okay
um and it was 8 000 on the car right
yes so i could be i could pay it all off
in six months but i wanna i'm so eager
to be out of debt it's like do i i need
to do it in three months i need to get
it done
do it in two
sell everything and then start driving
uber after work
get done man get done yeah two months
yeah sell the motorcycle sell all the
stuff because what you're doing is
you're resetting your brain into a
different groove
and the groove is i'm going to follow
this to a t and i'm going to follow it
with intensity and that that sets your
that sets your pal your life pattern up
your habit patterns up to carry forward
another decade
if you do that the more extreme you get
the more you deepen that groove is what
we're saying that's what the gazelle
intensity thing is that's really the
essence of it the one challenge i have
when folks are able to sell everything
their way to it is you don't have to do
behavior change you can sell some stuff
but he's going to have to because he's
got four thousand in in krypto and
stocks he's got two thousand motorcycles
he's got eight thousand on the car so
he's still two thousand in the hole so
and you gotta keep a thousand back so
three thousand in the hole
and so let's just get in attack mode
right here and and like john said work
like a crazy man take all the extra
hours you can get doing something and um
you know before the end of the summer
you should be 100 debt free and you will
have adjusted your mind to fit this the
rest of the time and you will never do
it again no never yeah
and um you know i
it's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes yeah and that's how i answer
questions here knowing what i know
having coached millions of people um
build on becoming wealthy
um you know what is the shortest
possible right path to do it and it is
deep levels of sacrifice
and because that permanently changes who
you are
you know john the negative thing about
uh
me and sharon going broke in our 20s and
losing uh three million dollars worth of
real estate that i had borrowed too much
on
and losing everything and the year
rachel's born we have to file bankruptcy
because we're just completely devastated
financially emotionally spiritually and
everything the the beauty of that
extreme experience is the change that
resulted from it was permanent yeah
yeah it was a deep deep deep groove
and i've never gotten out of that groove
again yeah i've never got there was a
deep ditch i couldn't get out of the in
your brain the way you know
and it's um
the neuroplastici
neuroplasticity i can't say it uh
research indicates now that that's
actually a physical thing in your brain
so let me ask you a hard question
you you make this switch and it happens
and let's fast forward a decade and
let's say you've you stuck to this in
your home
and then here at work there had been
seasons where
in a traditional business setting that
just goes to the bank for some man that
would have been nice
and you looked at it and said i could
take this shortcut here and go take a
big business loan out because i just
need to be able to buy these new books
or be able to get this new building and
you did years quick enough to do the
math on the back of a napkin and say or
it's gonna be seven years or six years
we're doing this the right way
that's that's a different level of of
behavior change that says come what may
i'm willing to
fill in the blank because this is the
right thing to do what kept you going in
those seasons because that's hard yeah
i was playing golf the other day with a
guy who's uh
been it was a
raging alcoholic and he's been dry for
15 years 14 years and some change
and uh you know we were out there and we
were talking about all kinds of trash on
the golf course and everything else and
i said so you know that one right there
i'll drive you to drink and i was making
a joke with him because we're good
enough friends he can handle that and
he's like no
and he got like he turned on me you know
he like back got up right yeah hair
stood up on the back of his neck he's
like there's nothing
going to drive me to drink oh wow
and you know there's that it's that kind
of a thing right and
that's the way i am about debt you know
and it's just no
there's nothing i want bad enough
there's nothing you can threaten me with
you can't make me afraid enough
to believe that this is the best way out
gotcha or the only way out ever again
wow uh and so you know i you know we had
this building under uh option
that we could buy for five million
dollars and we didn't have five million
dollars
and while i had it as a five year lease
with an option while i had it under
option it the value went from 5 million
to 12 million
so not closing on this is walking away
from a 7 million game right right which
is blowing my mind right
i'm getting nickels out of the corner of
the couch trying to get the money
together to close on this thing we
closed that with one month to go but
sharon and i talked about several times
if god wants us to have this building
we'll find the money he'll show us how
to find the money if he doesn't want to
have this building
we won't have the money we're not
closing on it no matter what it looks
like no matter what the gain is never
you ain't got anything i want bad enough
and that was that was about the biggest
temptation i can remember because the
gain was so large yeah now wow no never
again